[Music]
what I feel when I am dancing I feel
free I just feel confident I feel strong
I feel in control of Who I am
I knew this is what I wanted to do I
didn't want to do anything else but it
crazy
[Music]
my name is Akira Armstrong and I'm the
CEO and founder a pretty big movement
which is a full-figured professional
dance company I started a pretty big
movement nine years ago and I felt that
there was a void and mainstream media
where wasn't a platform for plus-sized
professional dancers I didn't fit in
even when walking into auditions I
didn't feel like I belong
the typical expected body type is the
ballerinas you know the long legs and
long arms long torso it's upsetting that
society puts this label on dancers
because for me it's about the talent I
had booked this major gig with Beyonce I
decided well let me audition for more
representation I auditioned for at least
five different agencies and they all
kept saying the same thing she's good
but we don't know how to market her and
I got tired of hearing that even though
I struggled with things it was my
passion it's something that I wanted to
do is something that I loved and I kept
pushing and kept pushing and kept
pushing and it just got to a point where
I was like this is really what I want to
do we came up with the name pretty big
and from there I said I need a pack of
girls who know how to move who know how
to dance we have a range of young ladies
who are professional dancers they work
hard to prove themselves not only to me
but also to themselves one thing is that
we do is our pretty big movement
workshop anybody is welcome to come to
our workshops I am pretty
and I am powerful because I feel nothing
but love in this life we do power
circles and that portion of the workshop
becomes very emotional each and every
day we have had people say I read
divorce I've been suicide I was a rape
victim I beat cancer so I wasn't gonna
let this pointless they just kind enough
to just spill it all out the
misconceptions that people have about
plus-sized women we are lazy we have low
self-esteem we don't care about our
parents we are non-existent and we exist
this is Who I am plus size and fabulous
[Music]
lion dancing dates back to the Tang
Dynasty in China I was really meant to
wore off the evil spirits and welcome
the good ones I am a 20-something year
old millennial but I still hold this
piece of tradition grab three rings and
make three lines I was born and raised
in Chinatown we do have a lot of the
Chinese traditions that they've come
over and carried on and passed on to us
line dancing is really important to
chine home because it is a traditional
sport it's something that a lot of
people do come out and they celebrate
around Chinese New Year typically
includes at least two people percent in
a line you'll have somebody who plays
the lion head and then somebody will
play the tail when you first come in you
walk through the door you can't just
pick up a lion head it takes about a
year for you to be able to work your way
up to that level Kung Fu is the
foundation of lion dance their stances
and their leg work it's extremely
important we're having you trained in
your footwork in your stances making
sure that you're strong enough to
physically hold yourself through a
routine but also a lion head because a
lion head is heavy specifically anywhere
between fifteen to thirty pounds
[Music]
typically we teach different routines
for each of the lines just because you
never know which one you're going to
play it
you can see this line dancing in the
streets anytime where there is a
community event will usually partaking
them in Chinatown a lot of people are
familiar with line dancing and they get
really pumped and excited for it so just
the energy in the atmosphere for me is
ten times better
it's really important for all of us of
that we are educated about line dancing
we do carry it on just because it is
kind of a lost art here in America for
me when I do have children one day I
would like to pass that on to them as
well I think it's really important I
think it's what makes our family our
family
[Music]
Mayan dances are a huge part of
Guatemalan history and religion and the
ancient ritual of the deer dance is
particularly important I lead a monado
as a remembrance de la creación del
mundo
[Music]
the feast of Corpus Christi celebrated
on May 31st is a huge Catholic holiday
in Central and South American countries
quad amala is no exception there it's a
celebration filled with tradition ritual
and dance as part of the holiday the
villagers of Pat soon come together to
put on the deer dance one you'll Gomez
has been participating in the dance for
over 20 years but this tradition goes
back much farther than that la danza a
bid is the lipo Caprice panic those milk
Chris Milano's antes de la hija de los
españoles hisako Sal volatile como esta
that energy Aikido cambiar the deer
dance represents it to your hunt
it's intending to show how humans and
other animals have had to coexist in
nature throughout history la ceremonia
cases maya SE hace una antes de la
celebración de Corp see a bonito
conserve and OU cannabis attract his
original ease pls originalist las
máscaras bueno low blow Asik algunos de
artes a nose totalmente uno dos guidan
hasta las máscaras
[Music]
you see la Mantella dasa monado es una
flautas muy especial approximate and
equalities estimate of the large in
gross or terezinha puga geometric al
capone a CSUN timorous Lucia mint a de
madera como que esto después de una
bendición de vida de su trabajo de su
see embrace commune sacrificio que se
hace es la comunicación otra vez de la
danza de una comunicación en el pueblo
ellos lo sabe ellos y los seres DB nose
[Music]
special meant a Sal a todo el pueblo a
ver todo esto y luego vienen turistas
national CBN extra heroes bueno premier
sagrado s profundo
Constanta meant a not a repeat a they
like sustained sia de los cielos entre
nosotros
[Music]
dance is something that comes in every
last one of us from birth what we do is
take that and give them an opportunity
to personalize it and then it empowers
us to dance at this level my name is
Melvin Mitchell Aiko and I'm the founder
of Northwest tap connection our mission
is to close the gap for underserved
communities with an emphasis on children
of color and really just open that door
for young people who would not be able
to have accessibility to the arts
because of cost to have those
opportunities that are it enriching when
I started off with staff I was working
for the set of Police Department and my
goal was their children that I got to
see on a weekly basis I would never see
across my desk tap dancing is the
foundation of our organization I strive
to make sure that children understand
that it is a dance form that comes out
of black culture
it comes out of protests and we have to
appreciate it embrace it and protect it
as we pass it down northwest tab is a
race and social justice oriented studio
and being an african-american male I
don't think had I danced at another
studio that I would have been surrounded
by so many fellow african-americans and
I feel like that has given me the
confidence to feel comfortable in my
skin and normal everyday life I don't
really like talking very much but when
it comes to dancing I am able to just
communicate in a way that touches people
rather than what they're just hearing my
feelings as I watched young people dance
there is this sense of pride for the
work that they do but then at the same
time there's this sense of fear and
trouble for me how much longer will we
continue with this struggle dance is
such an empowering tool we are
communities of many colors many genders
identifications but we are one drew
these children that dance we're creating
a new tomorrow
[Music]